-30 years ago, our first guests
introduced us to Bill and Ted.
Gosh, has it been 30 years?
Who were trying to pass
their history class
and write a song
that would save the world.
Now they've reunited
for a third film
called
"Bill & Ted Face the Music,"
which is currently available
on demand and on Blu-ray.
Here are Keanu Reeves
and Alex Winter.
Yeah!
Welcome to the show.
Come on.
This is so cool
to have you both here.
This is awesome.
-Thank you, sir.
-People have been waiting
for this movie for so long.
First, it was "Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure,"
then "Bogus Journey,"
"Bill and Ted's Bogus Journey,"
which ended with them
having to write
the most important song
in history.
Where do this one pick up?
-Well, we haven't written
the song yet, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we kind of blew it.
-Yeah, okay. Yeah.
-So it's like all those years
later, decades later,
they're still trying to write
the song,
but they haven't written
the song yet.
And that's put some pressures
on their wives,
the family, the daughters.
And then at the same time,
the future comes back
and has a little
wom-dinger for us.
-Yeah, they're not happy with us
in the future anymore.
We've lost our cred.
-Wow.
-And so they've asked us --
They've said, like, now it's
you have to write the song
in order to save the world,
and all of reality
as we know it.
[ Laughter ]
By a certain amount --
By a certain moment
in a certain location.
-Yeah. Keanu's gotten really
good at that Zoom closeup,
by the way.
-Yeah, I can't even do that.
Oh, it's fantastic.
You've nailed it.
I thought it was so fun
and so cool.
Kristen Schaal was great.
How did it feel...
-Thank you.
...for you guys to get
into the characters again?
Do you remember the day that you
were officially like,
"We've got to do
the characters?"
I think I'm kind of
getting into it now.
-Kind of, yeah.
I mean, it took a long time
to get the film made.
Chris Matheson and Ed Solomon
wrote a draft,
we worked on it for years,
worked on getting
financing together for years,
bringing Dean Parisot,
who's so amazing, on to direct
and Scott Kroopf who produced.
-Oh, yeah.
-It was a long process.
And in that process, rehearsing
and doing script work...
-Fitting the puzzle pieces
together.
-And never did we actually do
the voices.
-Yeah, we wouldn't do
We would work on the script.
And so we had
some script readings,
and Dean the director
would be like, "So..."
We'd be like, "No."
-The writers would be
looking at us like,
"Are they going to do it?
Are they gonna actually
do the thing?"
-"Are they gonna do it?
They gonna --" Yeah.
-So Keanu came over to
my house in New Orleans,
like pretty much the night
before We started shooting.
And we were rehearsing,
which we would do,
and he looked at me as
he was about to leave.
I was like, "What?"
He's like,
"You want to just try
the characters,
you know, before we, like, shoot
at 6:00 in the morning?
-It's just great.
I just was so happy
to see you guys
come back together.
Did you guys meet auditioning
for this movie
or were you friends
before this film?
-No, we met on the first --
earlier auditions we met
for the first time
and became friends
pretty instantaneously.
I mean, we both rode
motorcycles,
so we both walked in
with motorcycle helmets.
And the auditions went on
for months and months
and they kept pairing us off
with different people
and changing our roles.
And we became friends
over the arduous
"Bill & Ted" audition gauntlet
without assuming we were
actually going to be cast.
-Wow!
-And they did something
very unusual, where they had
different actors, artists,
all audition--
like ten people,
and like two would go
into a room
and then two would come out.
And then another two would go
in, and then one would come out.
And we were both playing
Bill and Ted,
and it was a kind of like --
it was like an audition
gladiatorial gauntlet
of Bill and Ted.
-Torture event, yes.
-I always disliked auditioning.
I thought it was the worst
part of the whole business.
It's so kind of --
-Yeah.
-They just --
-There's a fun to it, too.
Like, Keanu and I
actually had fun
in the auditions playing
the characters.
It was funny, because we --
A lot of time has gone by.
We'd forgotten about
the early auditions
and the specifics of them.
And we thought we brought all
this stuff to our characters
way later once we'd had time
to really think about it
on a deep level, and then
someone showed us our audition,
and we literally walked in
on day one as Bill and Ted,
like, just, like, no method.
It's like --
-You just nailed it.
-I've got my shirt
tied around my waist, like --
-I got shorts.
-He's got shorts and a jacket.
We're like ripping --
it's like the whole thing
is literally there
on day one.
-It was meant to be.
-There you go with that Zoom,
you nailed it.
-I'm not even gonna try to
compete with that closeup.
It's so good.
-It's that confidence of youth,
but I love it.
Obviously it exploded,
became part of not just --
I mean, just making a movie
is so hard enough.
But when the movie is a hit,
that's another thing.
But then when it becomes
part of pop culture
and people start saying
"Be excellent"
and then doing air guitar
and saying, like,
"San Dimas High School
Football rules!" and like --
You must have been --
-The best --
-I know. Do people --
I mean, you're probably like,
"Don't say that again," and
people are yelling it to you,
and you're like --
oh, my gosh.
But then you became toys,
action figures.
You were a cartoon,
you were a video game.
It was pop culture at its most.
What was the craziest Bill
and Ted thing that you saw?
Could it have been...
the breakfast cereal?
-Ah!
-I've got PTSD now.
-What, you've got a cereal?
Where did you get that?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-Cinnamon oat squares
and marshmallow notes.
It sounds pretty good actually.
-Yeah, please don't eat that.
Please. We care about you.
-It's vintage, yeah,
I will not eat this.
-It's not.
-But how cool is that?
You were a breakfast cereal.
-Yeah, I lived in a weird part
of L.A. foe a while,
and I remember walking
to the grocery store
at like 1:00 in the morning
to get eggs or something
and seeing both our faces
on a cereal --
'Cause they never told us
anything.
Like, they never said,
"Oh, on Thursday,
a cereal will come out."
They didn't pay us, either.
But they didn't tell us
any of that stuff,
so you would find out about it
when everyone else did.
-And so you walked into
your deli --
-So you walked into the store
and there in front of you
was a Bill and Ted cereal?
-Yeah.
And it was like 1:00
in the morning.
-Whomp, whomp, whomp.
-I thought I was, like,
you know, having flashbacks.
-In the Twilight Zone?
Yeah, Rod Serling's gonna
come out and be like,
"Could you imagine?
Space and time..."
I mean, that is so cool, man.
I have to ask because
I started with comedy,
so George Carlin -- what was it
like working with him?
Was it -- did you -- were you
a fan of his going in?
Obviously you probably were.
-Look how he's looking at us.
[ Laughter ]
-He's like --
-Deep respect and admiration.
[ Laughter ]
-He's like, "I'm eating lunch in
my trailer by myself today."
-Oh, God.
-He was -- I mean,
for both of us
it was such an honor.
I mean, we just were
such huge fans of his
and familiar with his work
and...
And though he gave us that look,
he was acting.
-Yeah.
-And...
-He was really nice to us,
right?
-He was.
He was a much gentler person
than you would expect
from the kind of razor --
the barbed nature
of his standup,
which was, you know, coming up
in our era, was it, right?
He was a cultural titan.
-Yeah.
-So we were pretty starstruck,
I think,
and grateful that he was
as sweet to us as he was.
And, you know,
he was a gentle guy.
We would bump into him
even after the second movie
out and about.
He was always very lovely.
-Yeah, I love it when those
casts come together
and it's like, there's
no one else that could do it
besides you three.
-No, amazing.
-It just worked out.